ne pas revivre l'enfer d'un nouveau
confinement d'une nouvelle salve de
restriction avec la menace du variant
delta mais aussi à d autres la france
s'inquiète et pour détecter plus
rapidement à l'évolution d'un variant du
coronavirus une solution existe
le séquençage explications le séquençage
d'un virus est en fait son autopsie si
on peut parler comme ça c'est à dire
qu'on recherche avec des méthodes les
méthodes modernes maintenant qu'ils
rendent cela possible en décortique tout
le tout le génome du virus
on a ainsi son identité la plus intime
et ont surtout on détecte facilement les
mutations dans ce dans ce génome qui
permettent de relier saint à telle ou
telle propriété du virus
un outil capital et pourtant la france
est l'un des plus mauvais élèves
européens
dans ce registre l'écart le plus
flagrant est avec le royaume uni en
février 2021 la france l'a partagée que
7000 séquence du virus avec la
plateforme internationale agisse aide
soit 40 fois moins que nos voisins oui
la france commence à rattraper son
retard avec plus de 40000 séquence
déposé la france est sixième au monde
pour le dépôt de ces camps s'agissait il
en décembre 2020 on avait déposé que
deux à trois mille séquence un retard à
rattraper certes et un coup de boost
plus que nécessaire mais en réalité la
france se positionne non pas à la 6e
place mondiale mais la 9e position loin
derrière les etats unis ou encore
l'allemagne quand on regarde à ce
classement ce n'est pas nouveau
la france a toujours eu un certain
retard à l'allumage concernant cette
crise sanitaire on se souvient des
masques des tests et des vaccins place à
présent au séquençage
il a fallu attendre janvier 2021 et
l'émergence des variants pour que la
france s'inquiète réellement l'exécutif
elle met alors en place le consortium
émerger une dédiée à la surveillance
génomique des maladies infectieuses en
collaboration avec de nombreux
laboratoires à travers coop là c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est
extrêmement sophistiqué qui demandent
des des capacités
extrêmement pointues au laboratoire et
aider aussi des biologistes qui sont
parfaitement bien formés pour
l'interprétation des résultats
donc tout ça bien entendu à un coût qui
est qui et qui relativement élevé mais
c'est un investissement qui est
important c'est les lycées ce sont des
millions d'euros l'argent nerf de la
guerre la guerre un terme si souvent
employée par emmanuel macron lorsqu'il
s'agit de lutte contre le kobe 19
on se souvient tous de ce discours assez
évocateur lors du premier confinement et
pour bien mener cette guerre il aurait
fallu investir massivement et plus
rapidement également dans ce consortium
génomique comme nos voisins anglais
encore une fois en 2020 le royaume uni
investi environ 35 millions d'euros dans
ce programme est ce qui a permis à
d'analysé environ plus de 70000 variant
sur leur territoire une infrastructure
scientifique qui a un coût comme on a pu
le voir d'où ce temps de réflexion assez
poussé de la part de l'exécutif français
en tout cas la question un peu se poser
ce boost de séquençage sera-t-il
suffisant pour suivre la cadence d'une
éventuelle reprise épidémique plus que
probable au vu de la situation
anglaise le doute est permis